first time I suffered a a quick show of
hands how many people saw the Falcon
Heavy launches
okay so this is not that story but you
know this is on the continuum of that
story so we now measure entrepreneurship
by Musk's so I would say where this is
about a to Milly musk story but you know
it's not a zero Milly masochist story
and I hope you can see glimmers of the
courage and ambition and techniques that
musk used in SpaceX in in what we did
with drones not just because of both em
in the air so I'm gonna start by I'm
basically over the course of this i'ma
tell you sort of my story and I'll make
it as narrative as possible but I'm also
going to be telling two stories one is
about the use of open innovation as a
disruptive tool and then ultimately a
business founder and the other is going
to be a sobering but I hope also
inspiring story about what it means to
compete with great Chinese companies and
without ruining the surprise we lost but
maybe we also won so I'm gonna start
with the year is the year is 2007 and
I'll show you some pictures of my kids
in a moment but basically think about
the aerospace industry as looking like
any other industry which is to say that
it was a very mature industry it had
lots of big companies Boeing Lockheed
McDonnell Douglas etc it's pretty well
populated around a slide that you've
seen many many times which is that
there's price and there's features and
the more features the higher price etc
and and you should and you should assume
that this is uh this is sort of who
fully populated and then you might ask
yourself why would anyone want to enter
the aerospace industry in our case the
air and Musk's case the space and the
answer is that there's no units on this
chart and if you put units on this chart
you suddenly realize that it starts at
expensive and goes to very expensive now
the second book is Matt mentioned I
wrote in the sort of the longtail
trilogy was free it was a book about
about the use of
zero marginal cost economics to ie the
internet digital distribution as
informed marketing and and and changing
a business model to a freemium business
model but the point is is that as
everyone has learned in economics you
know there is the notion of price
elasticity and that if you lower the
price you should discover demand markets
customers that you might not have also
previously found now the reason why the
aerospace industry sort of started at
expensive and went to very expensive is
because they were assuming there was
essentially one customer leasing space
and also true for drones
which is the business I was in and that
is the government the government is a
you know sometimes it's military
sometimes it's - it's NASA etc but - the
government and there's a certain amount
of regulation that comes with this
procurement processes and all this kind
of stuff and basically it's very you
know if you ask Elon Musk which I did
they said Elon mr. PayPal mr. Tesla you
know mister you know Solar City what
makes you think that you can go to Mars
he didn't say material science he didn't
say Moore's law he didn't say you know
software he said cost plus accounting
cost plus accounting means that the
economic model of aerospace is broken
the economic model of aerospace is that
is that the government says what's it
gonna cost to make this and you say X
and they said we'll give you X plus cost
plus so there's no incentive to lower X
because the government will give you a
profit on whatever you say X is if you
win the contract anyway I must say this
is a completely flawed economic model if
you it doesn't incentivize lower cost
and if you lower the cost you can
discover markets that maybe are beyond
the government maybe there's a whole
bunch of people who would love to put
things in space but they can't afford to
do it and if you lower the cost by say
10x maybe you'll find more than 10x as
much demand so I don't do space but I
did do something else
I did I did drones now I didn't actually
do drones as you'll see I did I did Lego
with my children but we'll get to that
in a moment
but the point is is that I am a I am NOT
an aerospace guy I am NOT a most even a
hardware guy but it was pretty clear
that something in the world had changed
to lower the barrier to entry to kind of
basic basic kind of computers sensors
autonomy and things like that and you
know for and I sort of did this
experiment I said what if you you know
what if you took the essence of a drone
which is an autopilot and he basically
said that's a computer with software and
what have you said what computers with
software these days cost about 10 cents
what if we just sort of put a you know
computer with software on a little board
and call and charge 19 dollars and said
you could put it in in any kind of toy
plane it would be a drone what would
what would that be like and the answer
is is that it was ridiculous it was it
barely worked it was hard to use it was
dismissed as a toy and and people
rightly laughed and said that's not a
predator that's not a Global Hawk that's
not a true and that's just a an Arduino
and a foam play and I said okay let's
that's cool what if you need a little
bit better and you know charge $30
anyway eventually we made auto pilots
for about $90 and we by the time they
stopped laughing we'd to put two million
drones in there we put more drones in
the air every week than all of the
aerospace companies in the world
combined and now at a certain point they
say well I guess maybe there's our
drones we hadn't really thought of them
that way and so we just said okay we'll
just put them in this here this is one
of them we said well okay if you don't
like the auto pilots we'll just put it
in a vehicle that flies and they're like
oh I guess that is kind of a drone and
I'm like and we're gonna find useful
things to do with it this is what my
company does today is we just use drones
to scan the world now we're doing like
you know what satellites do in reality
capture and laser scanners etc and we're
just we're now we're like part of the
construction industry and and no one it
didn't occur to anybody back in those
days the drones would be useful for that
they thought it was a weapon and the
notion that it could be a you know a a
way to monitor construction sites or or
insurance or or wildlife was
just not possible but this is what
happened and by the time we started
doing this and got the price from from
$10 to $20 up to about $10,000 the
aerospace industry woke up and said oh I
guess we need to lower the price and and
they did their damndest and they managed
to lower it to $100,000 so yeah this is
this model is exactly what's happening
in aerospace as well that the incumbents
who spends their entire entire life as
companies setting up procurement
processes and ensuring that the
regulatory barriers were such that
nobody else could come in suddenly are
confronting somebody who came from
outside with something that initially
looked like a toy but they had
accomplished the job through different
means so that's that's the kind of the
economic over picture now how did it
actually happen and the answer is it was
in fact Lego that's my nine-year-old
daughter Erin I'm at the time I was the
editor of Wired I have five kids my wife
and I are scientist by training and our
kids are not interested in science so
that we think that's a problem and we
keep trying to change that
it's a one day at Wired we got these
some products in for review some Lego
sent the new Lego NXT robotics kit and
somebody said a radio-controlled
airplane I thought that's gonna be
awesome
we'll make robots on Saturday we'll fly
a plane on Sunday something will stick
and so this is Erin reading the
instructions this is her brother Daniel
hoping that'll work
I the good news is that worked the bad
news is that it was completely
unimpressive to a kid
if you have seen transformers this
doesn't do it you know they're like it
where's the frickin lasers right what
why doesn't it walk this real robotics
is incredibly disappointing compared to
computer graphics so that sucked and
then we flew a plane and I flew it into
a tree and that sucked and so I said
well you know how could that have gone
better how could I've had a cooler robot
and a better flying plane and I was like
what if the robot flew the plane well
and so I googled flying robot and if you
google flying robots the result is drone
I'm like oh yeah I guess that's what it
drone is it's a flying robot wait what's
a drone the
Google drone and it's a aircraft with an
autopilot and like oh yeah okay yeah
play with a brain I get it
wait what's an autopilot if you Google
autopilot it turns out that its sensors
and computing software and it basically
has to sort of figure out where down is
then has to figure out where it is and
then has to kind of follow a path all
right go
it kind of sounds like what's in the
Lego Mindstorms kit it's computer and
sensors and software so let's just do it
so here it is the world's first Lego
autopilot
these are gyroscopes accelerometers
magnetometers non core processors dr.
GPS 905 Bluetooth stuck it in an
airplane and it flew badly but that
airplane is actually now in the lego
museum in Belem Denmark is the world's
first Lego unmanned aerial vehicle UAV
it turns out that drones and auto pilots
who are regulated as as missile you know
cruise missile controllers and their
export controlled and that the act of
putting this on the Internet was a
violation of Export Control we
weaponized Lego which is one of my
proudest moments so at this point my
kids lost interest and went back to
video games and I'm like wow that what
just happened around the dinner table my
kids and I made a drone out of Lego and
like balsa wood um you know this
something in this world has changed what
so I created a website called DIY drones
and there's a lot to be said for putting
the letters DIY in front of traditional
industries you know really expands the
mind and so what happened is that just
like a ton of people were thinking about
the same thing the same time as part of
the maker movement and did took off and
this community came together and they
started working on the software and
working on the electronics and doing
what open-source communities do in a
very kind of informal way and at a
certain point it would became clear we
had a thing as a matter fact we had the
biggest robotic community in the world
accidentally but this is a hobby I'm
doing you know part-time and in weekends
and it's we're starting to kind of
reverse engineer the military-industrial
complex as a hobby you know which was
not our intention and yet it kind of
happened it wanted to happen
and so I'm at that point and everyone's
like this is awesome you know code code
code printed circuit board you know
solder solder solder and then a bunch of
people come along and they've heard
about drones and they're like I totally
want to do this and we're like here
here's the code just compile that and
you know and and populate your PCB Oh
fab you PC B and to populate your PCB
over here and then and then like what do
you just have like a kit or something
that you could sell right we can do that
so here it is it's our first production
line
those are yes that my children the leg
of these parts are Lego parts the cool
part was that when I wanted the motors
fabricated this actually is for robotic
blimp but when I wanted motors
fabricated I I'm like I know nothing
about motors and I said I'll bet they're
made in China and I went to Alibaba and
I went to order motors because you know
one of the important economic lessons
you learn when you're when you're you
know selling things is that you can't
buy things at retail price if you intend
to sell at retail price you have to buy
wholesale to sell retail so I didn't
know where to buy a whole motors
wholesale so I went to Alibaba and I
found it was you know a company that
manufactures motors and I said I'd like
to buy some boaters and they like what
kind would you like to buy and I'm like
what do you got and they're like what do
you want and I have like what do you got
and they're like here here's a little
sort of you know widget by which you can
pick all the elements the windings the
shaft sides the magnets you know etc and
then just when you're ready you know
just just just pick the quantity and I'm
like I can design my own motors and it's
all it's all real-time translated
between Chinese and English and I'm like
designed it and then they are like okay
terrific I got to the end and now here's
a price promoter and I wanted like you
know hundred and turned out the high
price per motor for a hundred was like
you know three bucks each but for like
ten thousand there were like 60 cents
each I know they were less than that
like 35 cents each and I'm like I don't
need 60,000 motors but I have you
talking about how come there is this so
I just picked that and like ten days ten
days later this box comes and all of my
custom-designed motors have just ship
and been shipped from China is like I
can take two PayPal I was like I just
got robots in China to work for me
designing a custom motor and they took
PayPal this is something this
world has changed I pay the children in
in strawberries and juice we made this
so the good news was that it's sold out
immediately the robotic blimp KITT
they've had an autopilot but it was
obviously an easier one designed to sell
it maker faires then we learned another
important lesson about economics so I
went to the kids as I said good news the
blimps are hit they sold out immediately
and I'm like yeah whatever and I'm like
you know what that means and I'm like no
means we got to make more like no way
that's not gonna happen I'm like okay
that's a problem I'm not gonna make more
my kids won't make more what am I gonna
do so I found this guy on in our
community one of the first guys who was
there and I'm like his suit seems super
smarts name was Jordan Munoz and he was
he was flying a helicopter with a Wii
controller that was awesome
I was like Jordy you seemed super smart
you seem to know everything you want to
help me out here he's like yeah I said I
got little spare time I'm like okay cool
and he says yeah I'll get it soldered
get some some boards for you and I'm a
cool what do you need and he said I'm
Lisa parts so how much about five
hundred bucks so I sent him a check for
five hundred bucks and he sends me back
this picture and there he is stopping
the boards I'm like done okay hobby now
fully off in the hands majority 500
bucks you know maybe there's a lot of
money but I'm sure it'll work out okay
and he sends me back another picture and
he says so we um I hired some people we
selling really well we're now selling
you know other auto pilots and you know
other sensors and things like that and
I'm like he says we've got a little
industrial space I'm like that's
incredibly got shelves they he has a
bookkeeper it's really good in the back
they have a reflow oven for printed
circuit boards and there was a toaster
oven from target's that was repurposed
and like who knew he was such a pro he
sends me another picture he says yes and
we scaled up these are pick-and-place
machines and reflow ovens and stencil
and printers and CNC is in the back and
now about 30 people we're on track to do
about five million dollars this year
remember I've sent him a check for five
hundred I do not met him yet and I'm
like okay I think I need to go down and
meet him so I met him
and it turned out that he when I'd first
contact him he was a teen a teenager in
Tijuana and he had dropped out of
college and he and his hiddens wife were
just moving to the u.s. so that his
child would be born and become a citizen
so we had some spare time waiting for a
screen card and so this was like a
perfect fit for him and then he said oh
by the way we've opened up a second
factory in Tijuana and and the and here
it is and now they're wearing smocks
with our logo which I think I'd thrown
drawing in Microsoft Paint or something
and the thing I can't see it on this
picture but what I love about this
picture is that is that the you know at
this point it's really pro and he's got
electrostatic discharge protection so
there's these uh this is cables that
connects you to the machines that the
static electricity is dissipated and my
friends like me doesn't know anything
about electronics manufacturing or like
you chain your workers to the machines
and then at this point we're now the
biggest drone manufacturer in America
this is like the second plant in Tijuana
by the way I think the Tijuana drone
factory is a great name for a band it's
not taken yet totally go for that so I'm
like I think I need to quit my job I
think we've accidentally created a
different form of aerospace companies so
we raise some money I quit my job moved
the headquarters to Berkeley where I'd
gone to school and where I live and I
know he went so when I say we disrupted
the aerospace industry this is what we
did this is where we launched right
there this is the price of helicopters
import price of helicopters in the
United States we basically destroyed the
helicopter industry because it turned
out not because we make helicopters
because we made another way to to
levitate sensors in the sky and SURS how
a lot of helicopters didn't want to be
helicopters they didn't want to have
pilots they just want to put a camera in
the sky like you know traffic
helicopters or firefighting helicopters
or you know lidar scanning they just
want to put a sensor in the sky and
there's better ways to do it than
putting in
and in the sky a human in the sky so so
you don't see that very often remember
this is this is this is me I'm right
here at the dining room table with my
children and Lego right this is me right
there
sending $500 to a teenager in Tijuana
this is the teenager in Tijuana you know
building a factory on his own with like
by buying used pick-and-place machines
on ebay and downloading the manual from
the internet and this is the this is the
US helicopter market now we didn't do it
alone I have to say that this point a
lot of other people were you started to
use our autopilot and we created an
industry of people who are this kind of
bottoms-up grassroots approach to to
aerospace but that's pretty profound
unfortunately because of the scale you
can't see it starts at 1 million dollars
and pretty much looks like goes to zero
it didn't go to zero it went to about
$1,500 which is where we came out with
this but that same force that we used to
disrupt the aerospace industry was used
to disrupt us and a very good company
named DJI out of Shenzhen just did what
we did but did it better they brought
the cost down they brought the
innovation pace up and the price of
consumer term went from $1,300 to $500
and nine months which I don't think the
world has ever seen either and that is
that's the neutron bomb right that is
the end of the American drone industry
or at least the consumer drone industry
that's it boom it's gone everyone is
gone we're gone GoPros gone you know
Lilly and everybody it completely
vaporized the American drone industry on
the hardware side so I'll talk about
that in a moment so this is pretty
dramatic right I mean this is like they
would talk about disruption this is the
future of aerospace is being played out
at like you know at a light speed on a
global scale using open innovation using
all sorts of ways to get around
regulatory barriers without breaking the
law things like you know Export Control
and FAA regs all of them had exemptions
for
we were doing so that's pretty dramatic
and so basically this is when you pull
back this is what happened there was an
industry that was going like this and
was gonna continue going like that
forever until suddenly we came out of
nowhere and we're like hey it's just
it's just developer stuff it's just you
know boards it's just autopilot sits
just open-source code and they laughed
right then we're like hey you know what
you can actually put that in a in some
plastic and batteries and motor isn't
it's a pretty cool it actually works
it's really easy to use and you know
maybe the audience again discovering new
audience maybe the audience is not you
know the Air Force or the CIA maybe the
audience is like kids at Christmas or
maybe the audience is like construction
workers or maybe the audience is like
you know scientists looking at land
management so you know it made a really
cheap maybe you'd find something there
if you'd only maybe easy for them and
then we went really further and they're
like you know what maybe maybe this
isn't even about drones maybe this is
just about measuring the world maybe
this is more like satellites and the
internet of things that it is like
aerospace maybe maybe we're just
extending the Internet into the sky and
that becomes a kind of really big deal
so this is what's happening we're right
about or right about here right now
which is to say the consumer one is
still bigger but the enterprise side of
drones are becoming are becoming a thing
and so when you look at it when you look
at how we did this we basically
disrupted an industry by doing
everything they did we did it the
opposite right so and and and this is
pretty much it's not it's not a young
musk exactly but it's pretty close so
rather than high price we're like how
about zero or as close to zero as we can
get rather than the aerospace industry
which has an impactful record of safety
it has never been safer to fly a
compliant a jetliner today we're like
how about if we crash all the time in
the beginning because we're learning but
don't worry no one's on board so nobody
gets hurt and so it's like you know the
aerospace industry is like you know even
the notion of nines
you know five nine six nines of
reliability we like to spend three years
going for one nine because before you
know initially it would like crash every
time we flew it and then by the time we
were at about 20
2010 or so it crashed about once every
ten times which is pretty good
that's one nine then it crashed about
once every hundred times and that was
pretty much where we were ready to go to
consumer side cuz I'm never again it
your phone probably crashes one out of a
hundred times news and you know now
we're shooting for around three nines
crashes about one out of a thousand
times but it's no big deal nobody gets
hurt they're cheap you know and that's
the thing is if if you take if you take
you know if you if you take nines out of
the equation then the pace of innovation
really accelerates and if you don't have
humans on board then it that then the
risk of innovation the cost of of
crashing is so low that you don't have
to emulate the aerospace model we the
regulates the aerospace industry is
highly regulated its Export Control it's
FAA its FCC its it's you know it's it's
department transportation the works and
we're like let's not do that
let's not replicate the aerospace model
let's find ways where we can find
sandboxes where we can innovate that
have no regulations and so we found
under 400 feet within visual line of
sight no flight over people no flight at
night suddenly it's it's deregulated you
don't have to get these permissions we
said initially if you sell if you sell
to consumers you have to get FCC
approval if you sell the developers you
don't you have export control unless
it's public domain open-source public
domain or Lisa we argued exempted from
export control and everyone's like what
but these rules are written the 70s it
never occurred to them that cruise
missile controllers were going to be
created by nine year olds on dining room
tables with Lego and so it never in the
notion of public domain cruise missile
Crowell controllers which is essentially
when autopilots
it just wasn't a thing you never
occurred to them and this could happen
in the end it did so we just found ways
where the regulations were low the pace
of innovation as a result was high and
the numbers of customers was super high
again millions of drones in the air
while the military industrial complex
was putting hundreds of drones in the
air so this is what happened we we
started with these with these worlds we
sort of said hey there's these guys who
are interested in these people were
interested in robots and that was kind
of me and then there were a bunch of
people were interested in radio control
airplanes
we said what if we put the robot in the
airplane and that's the thing you saw
with that yellow plane with the logo in
it and that was kind of interesting so
we merged to two communities and that
was DIY drones and then we said okay
well that's pretty cool and then a
couple people said hey can I just buy it
and that's created 3d robotics now now
notice 3d R which was just designed to
commercialize the work of the other
community and then the RC people who
really like flying didn't want auto
pilots and they're like hey you know I
just wanna
I like sticks I mean I want the joy of
flying we're like great that's not
that's not you know that's that's not
for us
but still you know that that would
benefit from Auto pods to make it easier
to fly so the toys are manually piloted
video taking videos of things manually
piloted with drone racing is manually
piloted and that was good fun but that's
not the direction we were going then we
were saying we want autonomy we want to
make these truly you know pilotless
vehicles so we're gonna focus on the
software and the hardware side and that
3dr and that created the solo and then
we got our you know and then and then
the then the the the video guys who like
flying they actually tried to start
commercializing what they did and and so
some of them became pilots who did drone
services as a as the service drones to
the service and that's great that's not
what we do we on the other hand decided
to get out of the hardware business
because DJI was amazing and we just
focus on the software and then there's
the drone software that flies that in
the drone and there's the software to
analyze the data and we we did the the
data side which is called site scan and
that's using data to scam construction
sites and we spun off the software into
the Linux Foundation as an open-source
community called drone code and today
that's Intel and Qualcomm and arm and is
situated about 30 companies and today
this is the loop this is sort of the
Android of drones and it's all open
source and it is a consortium and it is
run under an open governance model and
I'm the chairman but that's that's so
this is the company and this is the
community and then and then there's a
second community which I'm gonna talk
about in a second called code Archer
pilot which is which is service
standalone and one sort of all
so in business and then one's more
focused on sort of developer
friendliness
and if this was a really sad thing what
happened between this fit you know this
is the splitting of the community into
two forks I'm going to take a second to
talk about this because it's really
important less than an open innovation
don't do what I what I did this was when
you're doing open source it's really
important to structure the open source
project both in terms of its governance
structure and its license in a way that
can be commercialized if that's what you
ultimately aim to do so normally when
you look at the continuum of open
innovation
it starts with things like app stores
API is SDKs except when the needs to go
to actual open source software there's a
bunch of licenses there's a general
sense that the more the more sort of
copyleft
the more radical the license the better
it is and the gplv3
is the most radical of the licenses and
IDEs and in in 2009 when we were setting
up the license I you know we had these
community members who are amazing
developers just the best I've seen but
they were open sources Ellis and I'm an
open source zealot or so I thought and
they were like gplv3 is the most viral
it will get the most developer
engagement people are required when they
use this to give back and I'm like that
sounds good
that definitely Spurs developer
engagement I hadn't thought about what
else that might mean but it turns out
that the GPL v3 and this is super
controversy I'm gonna get shot for this
you know metaphorically the GPL v3 is I
think a yeah was a it was a crisis in
the open-source community it has
essentially been banned by all big
companies here it is I would go as far
as to say it's toxic for business I
think it is fantastic for developers but
because of its viral nature because
everything you everyday very every time
you change the software you must publish
it it discourages companies from using
it because it can affect everything else
with this this is forced to expose your
IP and as a result nobody will touch it
anymore now this is not to be confused
with the GPL v2 which is what Linux is
the GPL v3 was a quite extreme deviation
of him and I think that fissure in the
open-source software community is going
to be felt for years and I made the
wrong
I went gplv3 with our G pilot and and as
a result once we decided to
commercialize it no one would touch it
so we fortunately had another group
called px4 based out of the ETH in
Zurich that another University and they
had chosen the BSD license and so this
one here is copyleft and this one's
permissive the BSD license the BSD
license is also completely open-source
but you don't have to read you don't
have to distribute if you make
modifications you can choose stupid you
don't have to and the BSD the permissive
licenses are the ones that companies
embrace and so we had to we had to do a
divorce and so one community went off
GPL and they're doing great fantastic
software fantastic community but really
hard to commercialize and then we
created a new a competing stack on the
on the BSD license and that's the one
that's now going to be used by most but
most companies including air taxis and
for example the new Udacity air taxi
course is based on the based on on this
on this stack that your own code stack
which is BSD license so that was super
painful I had to be a complete jerk and
essentially fire the community I started
because I made a mistake on the license
and you know I I don't feel good about
it but it had to be done and I think
that was something that we've learned a
lot about over the last few years about
the differences between those licenses
okay so I've got I'm gonna go with like
another ten minutes here then we're
gonna take questions so that was my
story that's that's what happened this
is part of it kind of a big idler some
bigger lessons about innovation and and
and openness but basically if you pull
back this is an experiment in the nature
of the firm and you've probably seen
these guys before this is Ronald Coase
mean of this sort of who's who's theory
of the firm created this notion of
transaction costs and that companies
exist to minimize transaction costs and
bill joy from Sun Microsystems who
challenged that by saying whoever you
are the smartest people in the world
don't work for you so Ronald Coase says
the only way to get things done is if
people work for you and Bill joy says
well that may be true but the smartest
people don't work for you jobs so - with
terrible graphics and I know these are
not the worst graphics that have been on
this
but they're probably close this is what
coach said ko said hey transaction costs
are very high until you create a company
roles and responsibilities under one
roof easy to communicate everyone has
this knows what they do and the can
transaction costs drop as the company as
the company gets more bigger and more
professional and as you know that's not
true it's true to a point but at certain
point companies get big and bureaucratic
and then the transaction costs rise
again so that's kind of a problem right
you know we just seen GE one of the best
companies in the world you know hit a
hit a hit you know the you know this is
a GE who sort of through a great
management to manage to keep themselves
here but you know but they were
competing with companies that were down
they were down here and so even GE found
that the the disadvantages of being big
a bureaucratic outweighed the advantages
so what do you do about that and the
answer is as I as we I think we are
collectively learning is that companies
are a fantastic way to get things done
up to a point and that the only way to
get things done you know at scale that
continues to be efficient like a little
company is to merge a company with a
community so 3dr is here and drone code
is there and that is and that merger and
that notion and by the way this is you
know Stanford right this is Silicon
Valley we understand that communities
are a big deal we understand that having
open open open api's and developer you
know tools is it is is is the right way
to do it we understand the platforms are
more important than products we get that
but this is still a pretty radical
notion out there in the world and how to
do it well it's not is not obvious so I
think this is if I were if I were to get
you know coast and joy into a room I'll
bet I think coast is actually good at
this point is me okay okay so it
wouldn't be that fun a conversation but
but at some point you know imagining it
that's where they would probably agree
is that is that they're both right there
just right at different scales
so to summarize paradox that's that's
that that's right to a point that's the
way it really works and that's and
that's how you merge the two the few
theories
so my next so you know Nobel Prize
please okay we talked about SpaceX I
start on SpaceX here's just a little
data SpaceX is so we were competing with
the Lockheed's and them goings it set to
the aerospace industry SpaceX is
competing with something called the
United Launch Alliance which is a
consortium of a big aerospace companies
and I just want to show you the numbers
this by the way is maybe it's a few
months out of date but basically the
cost so Falcon Heavy has one quarter the
cost of the United Launch Alliance
lifter one quarter the cost and twice
the payload so basically it's its 8x
better pound per pound per dollar ratio
so call it an order of magnitude and
interesting that's very common for
SpaceX is almost always about an order
of magnitude factor of 10 cheaper then
it's alternatives and that's something
he you know he's worked on and what's
interesting is that there's price
elasticity in the in just in the in the
in there so this is the number of
launches so in in 2017
SpaceX did something like 12 is probably
got 14 launches and the United Launch
Alliance did eight launches so this is
this is an example of him using price to
discover new markets now he's first you
know this is gonna be micro SATs and
it's gonna be telecoms and it's going to
be you know roadsters to Mars and who
knows but basically lowering the cost of
access to space by an order of magnitude
is a really big deal and we're and any
of doing this with not just eliminating
price not just eliminating cost plus
accounting but also eliminating the
notion of disposable boosters and and
all the rest so your thing it playing
out there you're gonna see it playing
out in cars so I told you that ten years
ago I started community called DIY
drones to to kind of you know Bottoms Up
transform the drone industry well done
it again now its DIY Robo cars and we're
going to we're now the one of the
biggest autonomous car communities in
the world
something on the order of you know four
thousand participants who are racing
almost every week wheel to wheel but
we're not doing it with full-sized cars
and people in bore on board in the road
because I don't have a car and my I
don't want to die and I don't have
permission to to drive on the road so we
do it at subscale you know from go-karts
on down I'm here I go back how many
actually so actually I'll just go this
is what this is what looks like we just
have these these warehouses we could you
know we have hackathons every every week
we this is a Carl bass the CEO of
Autodesk who we turned into a crash-test
dummy the steering wheel is disabled all
he has is a red button that's a kill
switch and and this is and and you know
it looks like a toy sound familiar
that's that's a billion a couple billion
dollars of R&D but the kind of on the
same continuum you know we use the same
technology we use the cameras we use
tensorflow
we use OpenCV you know we use the cloud
we use the cost of this is about $200
the cost of this is well you can't buy
one raspberry pi's versus a bunch of
Nvidia you know boards you know maybe a
radar maybe a 2d lidar etc but it turns
out you can kind of emulate a lot of
what's going on me autonomously in the
full-size autonomous car space for left
for 200 bucks in a warehouse with a
bunch of a bunch of nerds and and this
is our data this is we're doing pretty
well we've got a neural network team
these are this is just the latest races
the neural network teams have been
getting are those are the those are the
the blue dots and the traditional
computer visions to think of this is
like a proxy war with the neural network
teams being like Google way mo and the
and the computer vision ones being like
Tesla and so the Google Tesla you know
proxy war is playing out pretty well I
would say that in this I think actually
I have I updated for the next one I
think the computer vision team has just
pulled ahead maybe it means Tesla's
gonna pull ahead but what's interesting
is that we're gonna beat humans by
probably about August so a bunch of a
bunch of nerds in a warehouse in Oakland
forty other warehouses around the world
using open source software and raspberry
pies are gonna be faster than humans you
know at scale it's 16s scale up to
go-karts by the end of this year why do
we do this well because it's fun because
we can what's the point of reinventing a
wheel that you know the Google and Tesla
already inventing and the answer is I'm
gonna go right back to the same thing we
did with with drones we're gonna do
things they don't do first of all we
crash all the time and that's good
because that means we iterate really
really fast and nobody gets hurt second
of all we're eight wheeled wheel that's
not actually happening anywhere else in
the world no autonomous cars are racing
wheel to wheel we do it every weekend
when you race wheel to wheel and we know
this in the car industry this is how
cars innovate is that the car companies
the Ferraris and the Porsches etcetera
they race wheel to wheel in Formula One
etc this is how automotive technology
has always advanced except for an
autonomous cars where we don't do that
how about doing that why would you do
that well it turns out if you want to be
safe and this is for those of you with I
think a lot of you have engineering
backgrounds but those of you with an
engineering background who understand
control theory there's basically two
ways to to be safe one is to be very
very gradual very slow very cautious and
the others to be very nimble very fast
very highly responsive so you know you
can you can drive like a little old lady
and that's the way all autonomous cars
all Thomas cars are the first the second
order you know effect about Thomas car
is gonna be traffic jams everywhere
because they're so conservative you know
they don't know what do they stop and
we're like well what if you just super
fast and you you know nimbly doctorat
dodge through traffic I don't know maybe
that's a terrible idea
but that's what we're doing I got other
slides but I think on that note I'm
gonna I'm gonna oh yeah I wrote a book
about all this stuff which you can read
but on that note of destroying you know
a bunch of amateurs getting faster than
humans by the end of the year I think I
will stop and take questions thanks very
much
I realized by the way I didn't I didn't
dig deep enough into the hole competing
with China thing so some of the
questions are about China that would be
welcome questions a plant how do I
compete with China um so the question
was how do I compete with China I
described earlier on how DJI you just
just just crushed all the American
companies there basically all the
companies around the world by being
really good at what they do
so TGI is a company that grew up in the
Pearl River Delta in Shenzhen you know I
described the the companies of that era
is the ones that were making iPhones for
ten years and taking notes
they basically you know the you know the
iPhone processes and everything about
app on the iPhone was was was something
they were they were really well schooled
on DGI so you know I lived in China for
four four years my children were born
there and I knew that they were that
they were they were yet that they were
not they were not yet just copying they
weren't just a low-cost manufacturer I
knew that there was a really strong
engineering culture there and and so we
were prepared for this we were prepared
for tough competition from China and we
had a theory which I'll get to in a
second but but everyone said and you
still hear this I can't believe you
still hear this in Silicon Valley
everyone said oh don't worry about China
they can't do X and sometimes X was
innovate or sometimes X was like global
distribution or sometimes X was
marketing or sometimes X was software or
design or something as far as I can tell
there's no X we haven't found a next DGI
does all that stuff they started global
they fantastic software fantastic
marketing fantastic design they innovate
everyone said oh don't worry China just
just copies I don't know when that was
true but that hasn't happened true in my
life um and since I've been paying
attention there DGI is innovating faster
than everybody else you know I talked to
like like the US trade reps and they're
like so did DG I you know dumped you
know products under cost you know do you
want to do you want to file so I was
like no they kicked our ass just fair
and square and
like it by the way and they kept their
prices higher than ours the prop what
they did is they just innovated faster
so what they would do is they would
release a product at fifteen hundred
bucks which is higher than our price and
we're like ah our products cheaper then
like six months later they release
another product at 1,600 1,500 bucks or
whatever and then that product they had
released six months earlier goes down to
500 bucks and so they managed to get the
high end of the market and the low in
the market by simply iterating so fast
and I'm like you know this is not
dumping right this is just innovation
this is this is you know a company a
country doing to Silicon Valley what
Silicon Valley did to everybody else so
what do you do about that and the answer
is we got the heck out of hardware there
was just no light at the end of the
tunnel I mean we lost I don't know I
don't know how much we lost we raised we
raised almost 200 million dollars and we
you know the course of doing all this
kind of stuff we spent most of it some
large amount of that was was lost and in
going you know and going head to head
GoPro lost at least 100 million dollars
Parrott lost 200 million dollars I mean
there's probably you know Walt DJI
meanwhile raised about a billion dollars
at a met something about north of 10
billion dollar valuation and everybody
else just got crushed trying to kind of
compete with the efficiencies of the
supply chain and all that so we got out
of hardware and that is I think that the
right thing to do
DJI created a larger I think inspired by
our model they created an SDK and an API
much like app all the kind of more at
the Apple AppStore modeled in the
Android model and that's good and today
we use the GI vehicles and they're
fantastic and our software runs on them
there will as it went from the product
the hardware to the data then things
started to change a little bit so people
are very happy to buy Chinese hardware
that's fantastically good and cheap
they're less happy having their data in
a Chinese server and so in November of
last year the Department Homeland
Security banned DGI for essentially
banned DJI for for government use some
today DJI cannot be used by the US
government and increasingly other NATO
governments are not allowing the use of
DJ equipment I don't think it's fair by
the way I don't think DJ is spying
but there's a lot of paranoia about this
and and it's one thing to have commodity
hardware it's another thing to have data
and I think that there was going to be a
war and I think Great Firewall of China
which is very effective at protecting
the Chinese internet from outside
competition actually works both ways I
think it's be very difficult for Chinese
cloud companies to succeed outside of
China so I could teach I as a hardware
company Global first Alibaba
$0.10 Baidu it's gonna be difficult to
see them compete outside of China
despite having a fantastic technology
because there's some real issues about
not just trust but also legal frameworks
you know it's one thing to say hey you
know we have it's terminal service we
promise to do right but yeah what does
the Chinese government are they
comfortable with these national
champions having operations outside of
the role of Chinese law unclear so I
think it's a really interesting war
being played out at the data side so I
think you know I think when it comes to
consumer electronics China opens it
we're done when it comes to the software
running on consumer electronics you know
we're doing fine like like apps on
Google phones which are made in China
when it comes to enterprise grade data
that I think is still an interesting
battle be played out yes in the back
Italy to be the body review of where
journalism is handy today journalist
question is where is journalism heading
today so I used to be an editor not a
journalist I used to be an editor and in
the media I don't even know what
journalism means anymore I know you know
so so so there's these words like media
and journalism and it's a like a lot of
other things there's capital J
journalism which is a kind of a pretty
well-established set of you know you
know church and state and you know for a
Fourth Estate and responsibilities and
then there's like lowercase journalism
which is just the Internet so we have
the best of times and worst of times I
think it's amazing time for writing for
personal expression for creativity for
voices to get out there and and also
many of those voices are accurately
reporting their world now their world
may be a kids soccer game
it may be you know something that
happened on their block and maybe
something happened in their company or
industry and so I think lowercase
lowered small J journalism it's
fantastic Capital J journalism as in
sort of you know newspapers with
business models good luck
I mean I got no idea what's what's yeah
where there's light at the end of that
tunnel uh you know we were I was in the
magazine world which is relatively
protected but no even that you know it's
based on it's based on a kind of a
broken business model a hundred-year-old
business model which says that basically
you've got a three a three party system
you've got you've got publishers you've
got readers and you've got advertisers
and the advertisers subsidize the
publishing to reach the readers and then
the readers sort of implicitly promise
to buy from the advertisers so this this
this triangular market well it turns out
there's other ways for advertisers to
reach readers that doesn't involve going
through that third leg of the triangle
and ie Facebook Google etc and they're
much more effective and they're
measurable etc so you know as as banner
ads died as display ads died as
non-measurable ads died so did this so
did the business model traditional media
and there's a lot of experiments right
now with paywalls and you know if you're
the New York Times The Wall Street
Journal you'll be fine
I think Wired is now experimenting with
a paywall and I think they'll be they'll
be okay as well but you know the San
Francisco Chronicle I I don't know I
mean I I don't see how that's supported
you know long term and what happens in
it as it goes away maybe initially we
have a huge vacuum I mean might you know
we there's lots of amateur journalists
who are very happy to cover the PTA
meeting and the soccer game and the
block are they willing to cover the City
Council meeting you know I'm not I'm not
sure we may have a gap yes the
community's got started yeah and the
idea of reverse engineering and
understanding how these established
products work what are there any legal
battles that you had to fight them what
are there any learnings from that yeah
so the question is as we as we kind of
reverse engineer did we have to fight
legal battles
surprisingly not everyone told me that I
was going to go to jail they couldn't
decide whether it was like you know
federal jail or state jail or Guantanamo
Bay but there's it's like whatever
you're doing you cannot be legal I mean
among other things you're you're
basically open sourcing weapons is the
way they saw it your your you know your
your taking you're taking military
technology and you're giving it to I
don't know
you know terrorists you know to say
nothing of IP and all its kind of
separate so we kept expecting you know
the FBI the CIA or the NSA to show up
and they did they showed up every week
and they showed up to say what you're
doing is really interesting can you tell
us who is using your stuff I'm like yeah
absolutely it's an open community here
they're hurt you can reinforce elf you
know they're doing it in public and by
the way if anyone's do anything bad
we'll be the first to tell you you know
we're totally committed to this and I'm
like so you don't have any problem with
what we're doing and I'm like I don't
think it's against any laws I'm it's
like literally that every time I keep
saying out is this the time I get sent
to jail and every time they said I think
there's I don't think you're breaking
any laws you know keep it up just be a
good citizen so we so we were we thought
that we'd get sued on patent stuff turns
out that one of the nice things about
disrupting an industry thirty or forty
years after it was invented as all the
patents have expired
there was nothing there's nothing we
never got sued and nobody got sued with
hey was the word of thing nobody went to
jail you know yeah they kept like even
the export control the inspectors would
come by and they're like they're like
you know I don't know what you're doing
but it can't be right and we had to
fight and we occasionally had to like
explain this and then eventually the
White House quit came on a white paper
that said that there's literally the
White House came by the white paper
about DIY drones as a model of
innovation and they said this is exactly
what we should be doing it'll be
lowering the cost increasing the
efficiency and by the way this is
consumer off-the-shelf technology if you
can buy it in Walmart it cannot be an
export control violation and so we ended
up spending a lot of time educating them
on this but here I am still still not in
jail
you already talked a bit about how
regulation from this 70s
is disrupting DIY innovators that seems
to apply to many industries and nails so
in regulation from the 70s disrupting
DIY innovators it in our case it was
just the opposite regulations from the
70s didn't anticipate the possibilities
of what we were doing so we found
loopholes but do you think you could go
hard the regulation was not as specific
you know today we work really closely
with the FAA etc but by and large we
were able to put millions of drones in
the air with no changes of regulation
whatsoever just using the loopholes that
were already there so we think this is
like Wi-Fi compared to the cell to cell
tower so back in the old days of
wireless if you wanted to like make a
radio you had to get a licensed
broadcast license you know paid billions
of dollars for it and then you know the
FCC and their wisdom created a sandbox
of 2.4 gigahertz and certain power
limitations and spread spectrum they
said look if you stay within these
limits you can do what you want who
license required and basically we had
that there was something called the
recreational use exemption and because
of the radio control hobbyists there's
this little carve out for something that
looks like a radio control hobby use
which is under 400 feet and visual line
of sight and it never occurred to them
this the drones would the greater
control hobbyists would end up
essentially making drones so we didn't
have to change anything on the only
exemption the only problem was is that
commercial use was banned
so recreational use was totally fine but
commercial use of required a special
license from the FAA and that was a real
barrier towards that last step of
adoption I described and so the FAA to
their credits after they got after they
could see there was just an untenable
number of applications coming in for
waivers they created an exemption for a
certain kind of commercial uses called
part 1 of 7 if you get a used to be
needed up at actual pilot's license for
commercial use so think about it when
you think about 1970s regulation and
think about the paradox here if I am a 7
year old child who gets a drone into the
tree you know and opens up the box and
walks outside you can fly no problems if
I'm a trained professional flying you
know with you know with it
Spence of equipment with all the all the
all equal you know the gear I am bent
and I have to get a pilot's license to
do that and so like why is it that we're
enabling children but banning
professionals and the answer is you ban
who you can ban right children you can't
send a letter to a Chinese and desist to
a child but you can set a cease and
desist or a company so we work with them
and we got an exemption so we turned the
pilot's license is basically a driver's
license and that's called a part 107
exemption today that's enabled the
commercial use of drones so that was the
the FAA by the way has been fantastic in
this and the FCC has been fantastic
actually the regulators have been have
been surprisingly understanding and and
helpful on this and by the way you've
probably heard that when when the Falcon
Heavy what launch went off they thanks
Elon Musk was the first person I thank
and the FAA was the second second entity
for letting this stuff happen so they're
doing great any other questions one in
the back there are no pilots so these
were the way these drugs work there's
there's no pilots there's no sticks they
have they've been autonomous for five or
six years oh they're policy because they
want a pilot so drones haven't needed
pilots for most of the decade
the way the way it works right here is
that you just push this and there's an
iPad and just press a button if they go
and it does an autonomous mission so
there's no sticks there's no pilot
saying you just it just does its own
thing it doesn't does it every hour it's
like it's like a sprinkler so so wait
for commercial use
they've been autonomous forever that
what you're describing and things like
drone racing those aren't actually
drones those are called remotely piloted
vehicles but drones are drones are
autonomous and cars by the just the
opposite it's going to cars are actually
going to maintain a driver for a long
time because again there's a human on
board and so there's a much higher risk
much much higher requirement
have a fallback so-called human and the
loop fallback for safety right now if
anything were to go wrong here there has
to be human present that's to be human
in the vicinity who could take over
control in case something went wrong
they never do with a car it's it's quite
important that the human be able to take
over control like instantaneously
because the humans on board at risk
there was a question in the mill yeah
yeah this is the last question so about
the human on board
what's at stake is that do you think
that they'll be kind of a segregation of
solutions and markets where there's one
where you have the high risk tolerance
and fell fast and but then those devices
or solutions will have to be kept away
from where they can be the harm and and
the ones where humans will be exposed to
the risk or longboard or whatnot we mow
and each other guys are sewing yeah
these markets really won't have an
intersection per se ven diagram won't
overlap or you see like within a decade
or more that failing fast and cheaper
will eventually stop soon that and now
that the way no one is you know it's a
really good question so there's there's
there's three domains right there's the
domain of little things flying
autonomously without people involved
there's not people on them there's not
people underneath them they're just
doing the thing
then there's when you have little things
and maybe even big things with no people
on board but there's people on the
ground who could be hurt and then
there's things where you've got like
people on board right so so with the
first one of little things flying around
people flying flying without not around
people that's salt that we do that every
day the second one of little things
flying over people were just getting
permission to do that this sort of the
the the second iteration of that is
bigger things with no people on board
but flying over people and that's like
thrown delivery like Amazon drone
delivery or Google drone delivery and
we're still trying to figure out the
rules on that probably the easiest way
to do is not fly
people like fly over water and things
like that rural areas etc well that
that's probably in the next five years
then you get to the big things with
people on board also flying over people
and that's the air taxi you know
scenario that one's gonna be tough you
know I'm I'm one of the advisors on a
bunch of several companies in this space
Uber's got a conference every year
called elevate about about this in
particular one thing we talk a lot about
is the red button so you're in a you
you're now in the uber air taxi so you
you took out your app you said I wanna I
wanna you know I wanted I want to fly to
San Francisco and so it tells you that
there's a rooftop around here somewhere
and you just get to the rooftop and the
thing descends you get in it you take
off you now on your way to to San
Francisco is there a red button so if
you get in the elevator there's a
there's a red button you can press if
you're not happy
gilad machinery has kill switches cetera
is there a red button if things are not
going well is there a red button and
this is an interesting one to think
about because let's say there's no red
button how do you feel about that you're
completely helpless right there's
nothing you can do let's say there is a
red button how do you feel about that
what but if you press the red button
what's supposed to happen
does the red button do anything in which
case maybe a parachute comes out and you
then gently land on top of a bunch of
people that would suck for them maybe
the red button is just like a red button
elevator that doesn't actually do
anything but it just rings a bell at
headquarters and headquarters says hey
what's up you know maybe there's you
know maybe the red button
you know instance aimlessly switched
into some manually piloted mode but if a
motor just died it's not gonna do when
you got we haven't figured out what what
what should happen you know when you
think about just psychology and this
sort of this sort of X X and the
negative externalities of the red button
it's it's super tricky especially when
there's no pilot on board so that one I
mean we're getting we're not gonna solve
it globally we're gonna solve it in
specific places so so like you know
Dubai will say we're totally cool with
it go you know air taxi from Dubai
Airport to you know something good buy
whatever we're cool
New York may not may not say that for
four decades so I think we're gonna you
know the future is already here it's
just unevenly distributed all right
thanks again
[Applause]
you